Caption: hello hello hello hello
Caption: welcome welcome back
Caption: so quite a few of you stay put which is
Caption: awesome Chris's talk that we just had in
Caption: here we sat down at the front on speaker
Caption: which obviously we really really
Caption: encourage TDD and following on we've got
Caption: another first-time speaker as well and
Caption: this one's gonna be my favorite I don't
Caption: even know the topic no idea apparently
Caption: you're all doing tight bit wrong
Caption: okay so we've started with that in mind
Caption: so our next speaker is again ratify it's
Caption: definitely a ratified room one of our
Caption: senior developers then Larry a big big
Caption: round of applause please about me great
Caption: things you're doing wrong they're a lot
Caption: more but we're gonna breach what I'm
Caption: gonna tell you what it is and what you
Caption: do instead it's all the way you have any
Caption: thing you want to say then get on
Caption: Twitter I won't respond to you right now
Caption: but I will get someone please Alex so
Caption: while he is talking well lets you add
Caption: optional type annotations to your code
Caption: to help describe the intent and stop me
Caption: from making mistakes so I can tell you
Caption: when you've got an inconsistency which
Caption: is like you're using a strange number
Caption: things like that and one of the core
Caption: principles of talks is that all valid
Caption: JavaScript ballots on script so because
Caption: of that
Caption: a few little quirks did you get as well
Caption: because now toss crew probably saying it
Caption: but look this the only difference is the
Caption: popular section so this is our variable
Caption: if you wanted to to credit function and
Caption: argument and you can do so the first
Caption: thing people do wrong well that you're
Caption: using subscript is using any any in
Caption: general and basically are using any of
Caption: big tours of problems in Cosco so what
Caption: is any it's the most flexible type in
Caption: JavaScript and basically like you buy
Caption: layout of using stock script anymore I
Caption: need help
Caption: maybe unit out but I can't do that any
Caption: any value is open any because this is
Caption: where you get mistakes you don't realize
Caption: you're making so look an example so
Caption: throw the reasons have any and what's
Caption: good about it well it's easy to
Caption: prototype something you don't worry
Caption: about type annotations getting in the
Caption: way and things like that it's pure
Caption: JavaScript which I think with talk
Caption: scripts where it's statically done in
Caption: the free time we get into that yeah and
Caption: what's bad about it as I said it
Caption: prevents the compiler from telling you
Caption: when you made a mistake and you need to
Caption: do all the work thank you
Caption: what do you think you've got is actually
Caption: what you do have so so look an example
Caption: where this can cause the problem what's
Caption: that good a function adding two numbers
Caption: if I try and give it one of the
Caption: arguments string tots good will tell me
Caption: that's a problem but if I have a
Caption: variable so looking at an example in
Caption: this case don't know I've got an object
Caption: I'm just an empty object inside that
Caption: block or until that scope is a string so
Caption: we can still do all the normal things
Caption: like to uppercase or split noise kind of
Caption: things and outside that block there's
Caption: not a string so hopefully narrow the top
Caption: down from any or object or whatever it
Caption: might be to be a string or in other
Caption: words anything bottom string and if you
Caption: do have in anytime
Caption: because you think that it could be any
Caption: function you're actually better off just
Caption: staying explicitly listening every
Caption: possible thing that could be so any is
Caption: really string or number or boy you know
Caption: object I'll
Caption: I don't know it's a bit annoying to
Caption: write that every time but if you do you
Caption: will actually get that start texting so
Caption: in this case the my string is a string
Caption: it was my variable
Caption: well tell you that number to do that
Caption: type checking first if you're one of the
Caption: lucky people who can use oxford three
Caption: which came out on Tuesday you can use
Caption: the new unknown which is kinda like a
Caption: type safe any so it's essentially the
Caption: same as that Union type I just showed
Caption: you the second thing people are doing
Caption: wrong is duplicating into places that
Caption: are related so this one may be gorilla
Caption: Danny but it's still something that can
Caption: cause a bit of frustration when you're
Caption: using talk scripts so when you came to
Caption: talk for a property name you need to
Caption: change every instance of that type of
Caption: property home waiver is declared so you
Caption: won't get right back to help thing and
Caption: basically you could even have errors
Caption: just because you changed apart so when
Caption: you change it then you have to change
Caption: your interface and you can even have
Caption: errors that are only actually problems
Caption: with the implementation so the type of
Caption: implementation for example if you're
Caption: using react and you want to render
Caption: something you say it's a stranger than
Caption: here comes a number so just still valid
Caption: things to render in react but your talks
Caption: with right so you get extra errors then
Caption: it's more hassle to go through them and
Caption: then lastly this is like typing that so
Caption: this is example of react labeled input
Caption: and an input so you can see that the
Caption: basically the same the labeled input
Caption: takes your label
Caption: and then if I render them in react you
Caption: never use reactive probably doesn't
Caption: matter it's just an example but you can
Caption: see that we passed through the proper to
Caption: the input from the labeling place so
Caption: they're related and they should be
Caption: related decide that when I'm using my
Caption: labeled input I don't like getting the
Caption: event that I'd rather get just the value
Caption: that is emitted and I changed the event
Caption: then great you can change I go back to
Caption: my interface and I see that I've got an
Caption: arrow so alright that promise gonna go
Caption: back and look at my interface and then I
Caption: go alright input prop so change that one
Caption: too and then you again and they say
Caption: you've got an issue with the on change
Caption: now let's actually the issue that's
Caption: where you've got the mistake we had an
Caption: extra layer on the way
Caption: so what's me to instead there are few
Caption: options we can extend the interface
Caption: basically say that the labeling foot
Caption: extends simple props with an extra
Caption: property called label to me that seems
Caption: like the parent being defined by the
Caption: child so not my favorite I prefer to use
Caption: the subscript map types in this example
Caption: pick pick basically lets you take the
Caption: from one property with these canines and
Caption: use that sorry whichever way you do it
Caption: you'll get your tight changes pointing
Caption: through automatically and you'll see the
Caption: errors for the implementation not first
Caption: time so a little bit about thick like I
Caption: said it lets you pick some properties
Caption: off the type one thing I always forget
Caption: to do Oh mistake always make is we went
Caption: on separating the property names that
Caption: strings by using coma and it goes me mo
Caption: Tonio for that so I use a pipe and
Caption: hopefully someone will remember that and
Caption: maybe I'll remember that
Caption: so there's no the map plots they come
Caption: built-in with Todd scripts there's
Caption: read-only which is really useful if you
Caption: want something to be immutable
Caption: it takes the talks that you've got but
Caption: adds a read-only keyword inside of it
Caption: essentially so you helped you with a new
Caption: one and that can be useful to different
Caption: types so we'll give you the keys that
Caption: are in one but not the other that can be
Caption: good the third thing people do wrong is
Caption: not taking advantage of toxic compiler
Caption: options this is probably bigger than the
Caption: second one but I want at the end of it
Caption: of thing
Caption: so you see you can pile our options in
Caption: your case come things like Jason well we
Caption: don't looking at that often I don't but
Caption: good thing first one in strict mode now
Caption: this is on by default when you start a
Caption: new task or project if you don't really
Caption: have a sales company Dutch boy when you
Caption: run can see in it at least if you don't
Caption: but strict mode gives you a whole lot of
Caption: extra stuff so two of the options are
Caption: unknown for Danny which is autumn or
Caption: about and strict no kicks which also
Caption: talk a bit more about these other ones
Caption: trig function types and whatever they're
Caption: also useful but big holy most easy
Caption: strict mode and you'll be fine and these
Caption: other ones they're not part of the
Caption: strict things but they helped me find
Caption: bugs and unused locals or implicit
Caption: returns so no equipted any no one puts
Caption: it any is a big deal because like I said
Caption: before when you use any you're accepting
Caption: the risk and basically went our Krypton
Caption: and further cut because it can't figure
Caption: it out then it will give you a default
Caption: implicit any and that means you don't
Caption: realize they're accepting the risk so
Caption: when you have this compiler option set
Caption: and you have any posted any you'll get
Caption: an error
Caption: right on the line on your thing and all
Caption: say no argument first implicitly hasn't
Caption: any type or integrity of the place any
Caption: thought so all you need to do if you
Caption: think you haven't anything it just put
Caption: the annotation no chicks as anyone heard
Caption: of the billion dollar mistake this is
Caption: Tony Hoare was making a type system or
Caption: Algol W which I've never heard of and
Caption: don't really want to use but he was the
Caption: first card about a null reference
Caption: exception and in 2009 he said that he
Caption: thinks it's cause the billion dollars of
Caption: damage so javascript has to go into no
Caption: there's no and under time so you can say
Caption: that javascript is going go on mistake
Caption: so stricken objects will hope you get
Caption: around this so it'll force you to
Caption: annotate when something could be no and
Caption: then based on that it will make sure
Caption: that when you're using it you're
Caption: checking that it's not know how did we
Caption: get here at all well it's important to
Caption: remember that talk scripts isn't
Caption: actually a language that anything knows
Caption: about that your editor
Caption: you generally compile it all the way and
Caption: you're just running JavaScript for the
Caption: browser so if you've ever said the
Caption: compiler will handle that for me or
Caption: that'll never happen then you could have
Caption: some of these issues and it's important
Caption: to remember there's no runtime type
Caption: checking so just because you said
Caption: something to be a number doesn't mean it
Caption: is it's especially important when you're
Caption: working with like third parties it's
Caption: written if I don't have any type
Caption: annotations you might think it's a
Caption: string but is it really so you can add
Caption: those type of checks in places that make
Caption: sense you know you don't wanna go to
Caption: literally a code within one every single
Caption: function but it's important but you
Caption: don't know what you're getting you can
Caption: do those checks and I'm nine type well
Caption: for that you don't know what you're
Caption: getting and
Caption: compiler will actually force you to do
Caption: that you any worry so to recap the three
Caption: things not to do
Caption: remember those risky to you Danny and
Caption: use something else instead so unknown
Caption: all the big Union you probably actually
Caption: have all of them you've probably got
Caption: let's say the spring or a number in
Caption: which case that's a lot less tie things
Caption: and the whole thing map flux are better
Caption: than duplicating interfaces Rolex code
Caption: and you way as if there is to go through
Caption: Turner's prick mode that's a big one
Caption: that will help you find a lot of
Caption: problems and remember it's doing
Caption: JavaScript now if there's anything else
Caption: I've missed or anything you've seen that
Caption: people do wrong or that I've got wrong
Caption: then tweet me you past activity or no
Caption: any my favorite yeah then you know got a
Caption: few raisins besides you get sent out so
Caption: that's fine
Caption: so it's three about things I'm talking
Caption: about next for things you might think
Caption: are interesting and other man thank you
Caption: love your work right that was absolutely
Caption: brilliant and thanks guys big and also
Caption: bourget's now we've actually got the
Caption: luxury of having to three minutes for
Caption: some questions
Caption: so that's a no yeah I've got one down
Caption: the front awesome coming to you
Caption: it's basically the same as so basically
Caption: let you do things like union types which
Caption: is both separated by the pipe so I might
Caption: say yeah yeah so I might have something
Caption: like an expiry date type and rather than
Caption: have to clear that everywhere and say
Caption: this is actually a novel thing hasn't
Caption: been once file you just say that it's
Caption: date or no and then I can use that
Caption: expiry date to opera have an expiry date
Caption: and I don't know worry about the null
Caption: I'm taking everywhere I can you know
Caption: that way so that's or if you want to
Caption: take props and walkable places you can
Caption: do intersection so I might have another
Caption: one that's all the properties so it's a
Caption: way of joining two things together or
Caption: everything types as well
Caption: or the one with obvious
Caption: probably things up there like cooking
Caption: spray or something on that yeah yeah so
Caption: you can export types anything about that
Caption: as well but yeah I always or in this
Caption: case thanks Ben
Caption: so when I lied we haven't got any more
Caption: time for any more questions because that
Caption: was more of a conversation so thank you
Caption: very very much
Caption: and another feet round of applause but
Caption: then Larry please
Caption: [Applause]